a huge television event that's happening
this weekend everyone's talking about
the big premiere I can't wait I'm a huge
fan yeah yeah me too I think everybody
is excited about this yes yes of course
we are yes well okay
based on your outfit it's pretty obvious
you serve very excited about the show
indeed it is a feast for the eyes and
mind a show we're a proud clan must
fight for survival in a realm of six
blood and fire yeah yeah I know we are
all excited
sheesh just do you hear the piercing
shriek of the icy wind Conan something
is coming and it starts with the W yes
we all know right we know what you're
talking about winter is coming yeah
winter I am speaking of burgers
[Laughter]
Waal burgers the reality show about Mark
Wahlberg's family trying to run a burger
joint in Boston that's what you're
talking about
hey yes that is the very same wool
burgers of which I speak of all the
tales ever told none is my thunderously
epic than the saga of clan Wahlberg and
their perilous quest to cook
cheeseburgers while arguing wait a
minute wait a minute any reality show
about cheeseburgers really possibly be
that good oh can a question asked by you
possibly be that dumb I'm sorry I'm
sorry Conan I didn't mean to insult you
it just seems to me that you're pretty
dumb I'm just not gonna let you sit
there and talk to me that way fine I'll
stand up anyway done done
I know what will convince you that wall
burgers is a great show I'll read you
just a few of the exciting episode
recaps okay I really don't think episode
number 107 Paul Wahlberg and his kids
visit Mark Wahlberg's family in Los
Angeles Wow okay I have to be honest it
does not be showed number 265 Donnie
Wahlberg's trip to the grand opening of
the second Orlando wall burgers is
diverted when Joey fat one seeks his
advice for a new hot dog restaurant holy
crap Joey fact one Tony it's pronounced
Fatone episode number 574 bird attends
the grand opening of the Cleveland wall
burgers yes and that's it that's the
whole recap honestly I gotta say this
sounds like the worst show ever I know
how to win you over Conan I've order to
summon my wing it mystical companions
all the way from Winterfell to bring you
a gift basket full of stylish Wahlberg's
merchandise they're actually my interns
Oh Brad this is wall burgers merch it's
a basket of dead snakes
I'm sorry Conan Eagles make terrible
interns
well great well now flies are buzzing
around the dead snakes makes sense
listen I'll send my other intern Gary to
take care of the Flies wait a minute is
Gary another eagle oh no he's a bat
bring out Gary
oh hello Angela what's that you brought
me a strobe with a spoiler from next
season of wall burgers I can't wait to
see what it says onions
wow what a spoiler anyway have I
convinced you that wall Burgess is a
great show give me some room come on
give me a little room I really like you
they're not realistic now wait a minute
I have one question for you if you don't
like Game of Thrones why in god's name
are you dressed like that oh this is
what I wear to sex parties to the sex
party
[Applause]
what an incredible optical illusion can
I suggest we have these flies around me
every night I do notes